ces robots créés par des jeunes âgés de
7 à 18 ans ont une mission de la plus
haute importance
ériger un village sur la lune à cette
fin chaque équipe à 90 secondes pour
assembler des matériaux de construction
celle qui rapporte le plus d'éléments
gagne la partie
au début c'était difficile car on
n'allait pas beaucoup d'entraînements
l'a cru qu'on va jamais on va jamais
s'en sortir on a réussi à se qualifier
les marchés en quarts de finale
malheureusement pour les jeunes
trappistes l' aventure s'arrête là en
revanche l'équipe de montigny le
bretonneux remporte le prix du
développement durable c'est une fierté
c'est une première année et donc on n'a
pas fait très loin dans le podium et on
est content d'avoir eu un prix si tous
les participants n'ont pas empoché de
prix ils savent désormais construire un
robot à travers cette compétition
l'association planète sciences veut
sensibiliser les jeunes aux matières
scientifiques avec un objectif c'est
drôle un peu la science la science
joyeuse on prend du temps on passe du
temps en équipe pour réaliser un projet
et puis à la fin du projet on vient se
confronter à d'autres équipes dans un
joyeux
voilà une joyeuse confrontation un
joyeux match qui se termine voilà par
beaucoup de vainqueurs et beaucoup de
plaisir dans l'est dans les ateliers des
équipes dans sa mission l'association
est épaulé par des partenaires officiels
comme le centre national d'études
spatiales le cnes dont on pouvait voir
le logo sur certaines tenues
c'est une équipe de savigny-le-temple en
seine-et-marne qui a atteint le haut du
podium
elle participera donc en avril prochain
à la finale nationale
quant aux autres pas de regrets ils se
préparent déjà à revenir l'an prochain